Russell Brand hasn't exactly disappeared
but it's been a while since the lanky
whip-smart
British comedian have been given the
movie star treatment his hilarious turn
and forgetting sarah marshall made him
seem well positioned to own the silver
screen starring roles in more movies a
shot at headlining the arthur franchise
reboot and his own late night talk show
followed making it seem like brands big
personality and the great comic talents
were in high demand and would say that
way but lately he seems to have
disappeared from the multiplex
altogether let's take a look at some of
the reasons we don't hear from Russell
Brand so much anymore get him to the
theaters brand earned raises the
breakout star of forgetting sarah
marshall a movie already notable for
launching Jason Siegel's big screen
writing and acting career in the movie
bran played the ostensible villain a
pretentious British rock star named
Aldous snow but despite the characters
many floors brand made oldest entirely
likable he was such an audience favorite
in the film that the producers put
together getting to the Greek a spin-off
movie centred on the character
co-starring Jonah Hill as a record label
employee who has to get snow to an
important concert at the historic Greek
Theatre in Los Angeles the movie didn't
quite click as well with audiences of
Sarah Marshall did that may have been a
hint some moviegoers might prefer
Russell Brand and small doses rather
than a starring role that certainly
seems to be the case for his next big
chance of the marquee in 2011 brand
filmed a remake of the oscar-nominated
1981 comedy Arthur and in it Brand who
have a history of addiction played a
believable sad drunk but remakes have an
uphill climb and the audience's failed
to turn out slowing his film career
momentum hosting the buckle among his
first high-profile gigs in America was
his turn hosting the 2008 MTV Video
Music Awards the show had a long history
of using comedians of hopes but
unfortunately it didn't go so well for
brand while he was expected to make fun
of sacred cows brand went too far for a
lot of people mocking the Jonas Brothers
public pledges to abstain from sex until
marriage and the purity ring's they wore
to signify it later in the show
fellow purity ring wearer Jordin Sparks
lashed out M on stage and this prompted
brands are awkwardly returned to the
subject on stage and declare I'd like to
take this opportunity to say no one ever
have sex again it's a mad idea
what a way to spend an evening voiceover
when maybe instead of watching him
looking acting like a rock star
audiences would rather have bran
disappear into a role literally to the
point where they can't even see him as
proof he's put together a pretty
impressive track record for voicing
animated characters he provided the
voice of the Easter Bunny in the 2011
hip hop and the ancient bumbling dr.
Nefario into Despicable Me movies at
least beneath and more recently he was
part of the cast of the hit animated
musical trolls talk show take down the
effects network got into the hot Russell
Brand game in the summer of 2012 by
signing the comedian on for a weekly
late-night talk show called Brand X
however the theory struggled to find a
niche in the crowded late-night comedy
arena and Brandon producers changed for
months a few times when the show debuted
it was little more than a sounding board
for brand to speak joke and rip about a
political or social issue as you already
knows my propensity for the bossy later
on he experimented with performer
introducing celebrity interviews and
audience advice segments and even
onstage debates with hate groups but
after roughly two dozen episodes over
the course of the year brand eggs were
branded a failure
and canceled sitcoms fabless effects got
rid of brand being himself on Brand X so
they could make a show where he
pretended to be himself in the same
press release announcing brand X's
cancellation the network revealed add
another project for the actor in store a
single-camera documentary style sick
common which he'd play a version of
himself
the concept was likened to HBO's Curb
Your Enthusiasm ironically the network
ultimately curbed its own enthusiasm by
declining to all of the shows of series
i slunk out you slog out
slunk I flunk out so you didn't do it
you punked that cat right ya punked out
I put their romantic rouse brand reached
peak Fame in October 2010 when he
married Katy Perry one of the biggest
pop stars of the day it seemed like a
bit of a mismatch
he was a squeaky clean all-american pop
star while he was a former heroin addict
under stand up comedian
they were both at the very least cheeky
and good-looking which was one of the
things that kept the marriage afloat for
two years until brands broke up with her
via text message Perry has spoken about
pain and sadness of the divorce and
initially pin this place on their busy
schedules brand later blames his exit
from the marriage on Perry's commitment
to what he called a Farid vacuous
celebrity lifestyle but he still came
out of the whole ordeal looking pretty
bad hurting his public image of the
Scrivener in addition to all his other
projects brand has somehow found the
time to write and publish a whopping six
books and kick off a career making
documentaries always a political
comedian and the curious guy brand's
interests and politics have kind of
become his well brand problem he now
spends most of his professional life
making documentary films about political
causes in 2015 he made the Emperor's New
Clothes a film about the disappearing
middle class economic disparity and the
recent recession and before that he was
hired by BBC three to make a documentary
about the war on drugs and whether it
had failed this project had brand going
to other countries to research their
progressive drug policies which was a
subject close to Bramha a recovering
addict he also made the 2012 BBC dark
from addiction to recovery hitting the
web in between making full-length
in-depth documentary films primarily
about individual issues facing the poor
and those living on the fringes of
society brand also has a youtube series
called the truth through news for
Russell Brand he's already made more
than 380 episodes of the series in which
he delivers the news while analyzing and
making fun of it
then invites on experts and pundits for
further discussion you think I'm creepy
yes meaning are you having a garden eek
so one of a revolution now I'm a brand
was never a monster movie star to begin
with despite having some key memorable
roles but he's proven himself to be more
of an insolvent man for films while
approaching other subjects that are more
personally interesting for him so while
his days are the leading man in the film
industry seem to have ended as quickly
as they began he still got our ticket
money if and when he does find up for
the next comedy sidekick flick in the
end you can still get a full dose of
Russell Brand these days you just need
to know where to look thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we do your
love thing
you
[Music]